[music]
>> Assalamualaikum. Wa alaykumu s-salam wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Now, uh Dr.
Zakir Naik, uh you mentioned that the
dedication and you asked us not to
follow your way by sleeping 3 hours or 4
hours. Now, what is the level of
dedication that uh we as a da'ee need to
put in in order for us to reach your
level or maybe like you say that to be
much better than you.
Is it means that like uh where Allah
subhana wa ta'ala says in the Quran that
Nooh
Islam days and night. So, right now we
might have da'ee who are interested to
be full-time da'ee. So, they just put
exactly 8 hours and that's it. They just
want to work 9:00 to 5:00 days 8 hours.
So, at night it's like you can't contact
me. So, I'm sleeping at night. So, what
is the level of dedication and
commitment that is needed to become a
better and effective da'ee? As far as
dedication is concerned, dedication
means
you are striving for sawab.
For example,
you join the Islamic organization
and the timing is 9:00 to 6:00.
9 hours or 10 hours, whatever it is.
And
maybe you're doing a job
where you're getting a salary of about
$2,000.
And the organization says I can only
afford $1,000.
That's dedication that when you get
$2,000,
you're leaving $2,000
and doing work for $1,000 for getting
sawab.
Now, that organization says the timing
is 9:00 to 6:00 or maybe 10:00 to 8:00,
whatever it is.
Now, if you're only bothered about the
salary, you'll only work for that hour.
The real test is
when you have to do dawah besides the
office hours.
That dedication counts. Maybe
that $1,000 organization is paying you.
No one will pay you that much amount
outside.
So, you're doing it for money. No
problem.
The real test is
that
if the organization tells you to do
something outside your
normal hours
and are not paying you overtime, that's
the test.
That's the reason if you're working for
an Islamic organization, you can never
go in loss.
Even if they underpay you
your balance will get in a shuttle.
If they overpay you
and you know you're not worth that much,
you have to strive harder.
The level of dedication is
that you fix your timing.
That's my time.
That's my office hours.
If you do that to a normal work, it is
fine because they're paying you for
every hour you're working. If you're
working for cause of Allah, your main
payment is the akhirah.
And no one can pay you better than
Allah.
So, here the dedication counts. And many
a time we also check the dedication.
You know, there was
one candidate
who said, "No, we want to come. I want
to come for the training program. I
don't mind doing this. I don't mind
paying a lot. I don't mind
many things, ifs and buts.
And same thing. So, maybe the person
taking the interview
what passion.
But Allah gives opportunity to check.
Then sometimes we test.
Okay, fine. You can come.
If you're willing to pay
fine, pay for the hotel.
The moment I said, "Oh, that's too
much." I mean, you were saying I can pay
this much. I can pay that much.
Tell you frankly
I don't know when people ask me
that how much do you charge?
So, I said if I charge you can't afford
it.
I do free for Allah.
If I charge
no one can afford it.
We do for the sake of Allah free. I
don't know the dealer.
When people make commitments, the
dedication is put to test
when you practically put to test.
Some people say, "Oh, I'm only doing for
cause of Allah, otherwise I wouldn't
have come here or not." But when you
tell them, "Why don't you work 2 hours
more?" "Every day ask me to work 2
hours?"
If you're doing for the sake of Allah,
the question of
working overtime doesn't arise.
Now, the question poses that if I tell
you not to follow me,
well, I as a doctor I know
that
sleeping for 3 hours is detrimental to
your health.
It's wrong.
It may be un-Islamic also, maybe.
Being a doctor, it may be un-Islamic
also.
But Islamic Sharia says, see, whenever
there is a difference of opinion, etc.,
the Islamic Sharia says, "Let a small
loss take place to prevent a big loss."
I agree it is wrong,
but I don't want to lose my Jannah.
So, I'm doing a thing which is wrong
for getting a thing which is multiple
times better. I being a doctor know it
is wrong. Many a times I and my wife,
Masha Allah, my wife is also dying.
So, she says, "The Quran says that night
has been made for you to sleep. Why
don't you sleep?" I could have read the
verse. Blessed are those people Allah
says who sacrifice their bed for the
sake of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala. So,
again, she's right in her way, I'm right
in my way. What she's doing, she's doing
the best. She's trying to tell me to
sleep, she's doing her job. I'm doing my
job. Who's right? Both are right. She's
quoting verses of the Quran. I'm also
quoting verses of the Quran.
But both of them are the Quran, both are
right.
She's right in her way, I'm right in my
way.
I mean, there are many people who take
care of a lot of their health, doing
exercise, everything, but at the age of
35 walking they die. I'm a doctor, I
know that.
So, I say that what you can do in your
youth, and Allah says, Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala will ask what have you done in
your youth.
Allah says, "What have you done with
your wealth? What have we done with the
knowledge? What have you done with your
youth? And the reward you get for doing
in the youth is multiple times more.
And Sheikh Deedat, inshallah, Allah
grant him Jannah, he's the person who
inspired me. He used to tell me, "Son,
you're burning candle at both ends."
He used to tell that to me. I used to
reply, "If I can burn the candle at both
the ends and light up thousands of
candles, I don't mind being extinguished
early."
If I'm burning candles at both the ends,
I don't mind being extinguished early as
long as I light other candles.
So, every idiom has its own pros and
cons.
When someone says silence is golden, I
said, "So is your voice."
The debating skills, we'll come to it
later on.
How do you turn
an idiom into your favor?
There are well-known idioms in the
world. If you use your brain, you can
turn it in your favor.
If someone quotes an idiom which is
against you, you can use that same idiom
in your favor. That will come to it
later on. That's the second phase of the
training program. But, alhamdulillah,
what I'm telling medically is not good,
and no one will tell you to sleep less.
I don't know any expert telling you to
sleep less.
Though most of the experts sleep less, I
know that.
This is because of dedication.
I know very well
that if I sleep, I'll perform better.
I'm saying I'm doing thing which I don't
like
for the sake of Allah. Allah will help
me tomorrow.
The help of Allah is more important than
me sleeping for 10 hours and taking the
rest. And to tell you really, I spend
more time in other things than this
course, and we'll come to it later on
when we reach that day.
The striving is important. How dedicated
are you for the cause of Allah, and that
will get you success.
Any other questions?
Yes, brother.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullah.
Also, on the issue of dedication, sir,
mine is not question, is
advice I need from you. It's not a
question, it's advice
I need from you.
Like we most of us are students
from different fields of studies.
How can we join
being is our passion to be full-time
day. So, how can we join the two? What
kind of advice can you give us even
times of timing ourselves so that we can
achieve both the two? Salaam Alaykum.
I thought of the advice for a person who
wants to be a full-time day.
Anyone who tells me
he wants to be a full-time day, I tell
him two things.
Either you do a course in which you get
more knowledge
or you'll get technique-based. If you
want to be a full-time day, you may be
at a zero level or you may be at level
20 or level 50 or level 90, whatever it
is. I tell him you can do two things.
Either
you join some course or some institute,
some college
join some university where you will get
more knowledge
or more technique in the field of Dawah.
Number one. Or two
you join an organization
where you can practically do Dawah.
A third is you can't find organization
which you think is on Quran and Sunnah
or the level you are thinking of, you
start an organization.
The third one is very difficult.
It's the last.
So, irrespective of whether you are a
student or a businessman or working
somewhere, if you want to become
full-time day and if you think fine, you
want to join
a college. If you are a student, okay,
join a college where you get more
knowledge of Islam.
No problem. Do courses where you get
more knowledge.
Otherwise, join an organization where
you can practically start doing Dawah.
Someone says I want to do Dawah but I
want to finish my studies.
Fine.
I always tell
up to A levels, class.
What is required for basic in the world,
you get it. Up to A-levels.
What you learn up to A-level, that is
12th standard, is basic what required
for general knowledge.
After that is specialization.
If you want to be a die, you either do a
course in Islamic University or join
some college or institute which does
training.
If you say, "No, I want to become a die,
but I'll do MBA." For what?
Fine, if you say that I want to become a
back end die, no problem. Back end die
means not in front.
Behind, no problem. That I want to join
to do management, Islamic management, no
problem.
So, that again becomes specialization.
You're joining MBA
so that you can start Islamic
organization, no problem.
The same as the student, if you're doing
above 12th standard science, for what?
Medicine, why? Because Zakir Naik was a
doctor.
Two things are very important in the
Hadith of Muhammad S.A.W.
Muhammad S.A.W. Hadith is either he has
said something or his action.
Either prophet has said something or
from his action
we take advice. But if the action
and the call, the commandment clash,
which do you follow?
If the action and the commandment clash,
Follow commandment.
The call is more important than action.
Action could have been done out of
certain necessity.
But the call, if there is no
contradiction in the call and the
action, you follow
But if there's a contradiction
in the call and the action, you follow
the call, the commandment.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah
Allah
>> [music]
[chanting]